we have 100 minecraft players trapped
here and we installed the world's best
hacks
we're hackers we gotta ban ourselves ah
our first hack kills anyone within six
blocks of us watch me do it bada boom
bada big they're backing away they're
all so scared
and here's how it works earlier today we
bought a brand new honda civic that bad
baby
is special and whoever kills me or one
of the boys first gets the honda civic
server drop the gate
hey boys boys let's start off by
fighting with no hacks ah they're
bullying me
all right all right screw it turn on the
heck everyone turn on hacks
x x x x x x x x
bye-bye i'm hitting them from eight
blocks away oh my god oh look at this
gnome
sorry buddy oh no why'd you hit the
gnome he was hiding
anytime they try to get near us look the
sword just hits him they can't touch us
occasionally someone gets through and
gets a hit off oh not on me
oh oh yeah no see look they occasionally
get a hit off hey squeaky chew
more like no honda civic chew
was gonna let you live sorry boys turn
on your speed hack
all right let's do it this is so much
fun
dude i'm just spawn killing him right
now oh you jerk
hey everyone camp a spawn point okay i'm
at this one i'm at this one with this
one oh whoa uh notice how i was already
here
holy crap i'm freaking zooming yeah
look we're so much better than them yeah
why are they so bad yeah why don't they
just use hacks as well
if somebody did use hacks you couldn't
even be mad at them this video but we
could ban them
we should ban people who use hacks like
coral no you read my mind
[Music]
i just hear his head said he is hacking
and you know
no hacky taxis carl give me my green
screen back this is my green screen now
alpha i don't even have to pay attention
to the game so i got 400 kills
carl's just taking my green screen it's
fine hey chris
yeah notice how you have a green screen
behind you yeah i don't
oh he's taking yours as well i guess
people just know what our back office
looks like
can you please unban me i'll unban you
if you bring the green screens back
okay all right yo i'm just murdering
people
i bet everyone playing right now is like
they're obviously hacking
it's just too easy oh wait i'm almost
out of food why doesn't everyone hack
oh why can't i just eat and run i can
eat and run
okay green screen all greened up carl
i'll i'll
unban you also whoever gets the 2 000
kills first
um can i get a burger for mcdonald's yes
you get a burger from mcdonald's
oh i'm really hungry
chris i have a deep psychological
question for you what's up
why do you hate losing so much it makes
me feel like a loser and i take it
so personally it could be for like a
dollar and 38 cents and i'm still going
to try ah
oh boys give it all the boys can second
place go to mcflurry
boys farm and the boys farming all right
me in the middle me in the middle
let's turn off pax for 20 seconds oh my
gosh
starting now what version of minecraft
is this
it's 1.15 oh i need to eat food i need
to eat food
i'm getting oh no turn it back on turn
it back on no
it hasn't been 20 seconds how many
seconds has it been
one all right i already put them back on
i'm good you know i can't see
i had to turn it back on yeah i was in
the corner dying
that's the best place to be in the
corner you don't have to worry about
your back bro
oh yeah you're right i don't even have
my hacks on no more i don't even need
them
guys don't forget if you die you have to
buy them a honda civic oh
we have to no but i just wanted to scare
you i was like oh that'll put me in
crippling debt
i think that might actually make the
video better should we do it that way we
need some stakes
stakes i still have 63.
i'll pay for it in high fives i'm
beginning to think you guys want me to
pay for the honda civic
ah yo i'm so close to getting this
burger
just back up i won't kill you if you
back up i'm about to get this burger in
and somebody better have a burger a
jailory 60 off
burger time 50 off 40 off 30 more baby
give me that burger
hey give him that burger oh you let a
man get a burger
where'd that burger be
and congratulations chandler you just
got a burger
hey hey let the man get a burger hey
let what is wrong with my friends let's
go
all right now that chandler got his
burger you have to turn off killer
you can no longer use that you can use
speed hack but you cannot use kill aura
which is gonna make this a lot harder i
don't have my burger we'll get you a
burger later taylor i'm cornerstrading
all right for the next 20 seconds no
speed hacks either all hacks disabled
my hacks are off my hacks are off
why is everyone chasing me what did i do
you turned off your hex
silly oh no i've lost three hearts
it's been 20 seconds we can turn the
hacks back on how fast are your 20
seconds
were you not counting in your head like
me no it got a little close i got three
hearts down they were they were doing
pretty good for a while
guys protect chandler i don't want to
give away a honda civic all right all
right i'm back i'm back jimmy i'm not
gonna lie to you do we have a time limit
on this because i think
no matter what you're gonna give a honda
civic oh no
guys oh they got four hearts somebody
help wait chandler where are you
use your speed hacks we can use speed
hacks oh we can
yeah yeah what the heck have you not
seen us just zooming
we're just flying around the map killing
people oh my gosh guys
you guys freaking suck for not telling
me i'm just gonna run and not even hit
them because there's no point i'm
running so fast it doesn't register
yeah it hasn't been registering for me
either all right then turn off all hacks
again what
i just had him off hey you're saying it
was too easy i'm gonna die
i'm gonna die my sprint's not working
you know our sprint's just really slow
when can we turn on the hacks again i'm
getting swarmed they want to kill me
maybe maybe chandler should go help him
okay i'm not gonna lie jimmy
i'm gonna be very transparent right now
about seconds away from a honda civic
giving dart you can turn hacks on
killing everyone do you guys need hacks
to survive it's almost like i've proven
to you every video how bad i am at this
game
but here's one thing to keep in mind
boys i bet your armors are getting
pretty weak they are
yeah well my helmet's about to be gone
holy crap when you're out of armor you
gotta learn how to live without it my
helmet's gone almost
like two more hits well chandler you
might be the one that gives away the
honda civic but i don't want to give
away a honda civic uh don't die then
haha
nerds how'd you get up there i'd just be
climbing and stuff giving them kills
i don't care no more bro people are just
walking up to me and getting
murked oh yeah pb we're gonna turn all
hacks off again in three seconds
you hate me hacks are off now i'm hiding
they'll never find me oh get away get
away get away get away from me
get away from me oh my gosh no oh they
all found me
oh my helmet hold on we broke oh god i'm
dying quickly
help turn him on can we turn him on all
right you can turn him on
oh my god i died no did you actually
yeah he died he died for real chiller
honda civic
everyone watching i apologize for this
video being shorter than normal did not
plan on chandler dying that early watch
the footage it was
it was instantaneous so who was it i
don't know i just got kicked from the
server
mr lasher you killed chandler do you
know what that means you just won
um thing you said at the start chris you
want to tell him what his presence
you just won yourself hey 2013
honda civic
um i'm 15. well you have a car for when
you can drive next year
yes and with that we'll see in the next
video